je suis allé voir ce qui s'est passé
aussi à la téloche et surtout sur tille
top dalle et que j'aime et j'adore ça
c'est le monde garde et tu te vous
connaissez évidemment la musique
phénomène de carla
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est tombé on est tombé sur quelqu'un
qui a voulu refaire achats manière
regardez ça fait le but partout contre
un plus énorme à bernard et ça fait
bilbao ça fait pschitt et ça fait
beaucoup mais ça fait bill bas dans ma
tête ya tout qui tout est bon ça va
casser mise en débat c'est pas ma fille
c'est ma cousine qui laisse un patois la
vidéo la plus regardée cet aprem sur
tictoc avec 3,5 millions d'us un
accident de gak jusque là rien de
l'audace au ski ce sont les commentaires
d'une touriste qui assiste à la scène
ils nous ont beaucoup plus regardées
seilhac équivoque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces permis bateau céréales avoir le
temps de passer le permis bateau s'ils
ont deux jours sont toujours sur la
scène c'est tranquille je suis je
l'avais le côté baba et côtiers
exactement l'alesco manger que du
chocolat comme chip cox est aussi le
royaume des défis les plus débiles cette
fois s'agit de rendement d'une chanson
en faisant claquer ses mains sur tout ce
qu'ils trouvent à côté de chez vous
regardez ça aussi c'est une petite
pépite
pepiton pour toi
[Applaudissements]
le retour de techtoc tous les soirs
c'est le monde merveilleux de tik tok
bien sûr alors n'ai pas eu le temps de
regarder toute la télé forcé bon bah moi
je vais en général à faire
j'ai bien sûr regarder m6 chasseurs
d'appart il ya eu il ya un nouveau
format maintenant il va pas trop
stéphane plaza alors on assiste à une
visite plutôt original avec notamment la
visite d'une chambre d'ado visiblement
là vous allez voir les enfants des
anciens locataires avaient prévu de
faire un petit clin d'oeil aux nouveaux
arrivants et alors moi j'y suis pour
rien du tout là-dessus soudure je n'ai
rien à voir là-dedans regarder pour les
enfants comme un certain qu'à deux
enfants qu'ils se séparent et une
chambre comme ça mais c'est très mignon
c'est très mignon ce très mignon ok d'un
13ème chambre qu'il ya la troisième est
juste quatre corps
[Applaudissements]
c'est très mignon l'objectif est qu'en
été plus sage et il ya des gens comme
moi quand même ça c'est bah c'est
magnifique ça c'est sa baisse avec
elecam et arrive dit il s'assure
apparaissent assez salée c'est génial
l'ours est tombée sur un couple qui
n'est jamais d'accord le pauvre mari se
prend que des cartouches
alors guillaume on a une grosse grosse
pensée pour toi ce soir tient le bon
bout
m regarde moi personnellement je vous
vois très bien dans cette maison après
il ya quand même un gros point négatif
c'est que il n'y a personne ici quoi
c'est en coupe et non dix huit mois ce
que je recherche aussi c'est la pierre
mon psy a pas de pierres et il n'y a pas
de [ __ ] ça me dérange pas du tout pour
moi je trouve ça magnifique lévy journée
au moi j'aimerais bien voir une maison
ça serait plutôt à la campagne la
campagne c'est pas trop mon truc quoi
pour sa nouvelle campagne ça peut être
intéressante non c'est pas possible pour
moi quand vous êtes en couple c'est qui
c'est qui le patron dans le couple c'est
ma femme c'est vous a c'est vrai à vous
êtes un canard laqué à canarsie canard
j'en suis fier et elsa est là vous êtes
à vous vous êtes c'est vous qui portez
là contre 50-55 ans à la peine alors
vous tiendrez bon teint canard ou
maintenant 50 50 par un ça va
moi j'aime pas les hommes larbin non non
donc c'est votre mec c'est le patron est
mais disons que je me laisse pas faire
non plus ça vous dérange pas et
simplement ils bossent avec moi alors
oui c'est lui à cent pour cent
à vrai dire que moi tout ce qui est
l'immobilier tout ça je m'en fous je
vous dire on a acheté une petite et bien
il m'a dit de venir le voir j'ai dû moi
non hrt boulez il était arrivé en bas il
était il a choisi tout seul mrc du bas
non fils at play sont séparés mais on
s'en sont offensés vous dire merci à
mathieu toi tu es plutôt je suis un
leader pas certains leaders d'opinion
soient absolument chez un leader et ce
leader dans la vie schnyder à l'antenne
je suis un leader au leader lotois
leader price
[Applaudissements]
l'accueil à égalité des sexes égalité
des sexes avait deux sexes elle a écouté
monde est content de le prendre sous son
aile
merci mais bon chien qui dirige c'est
votre chat qui vient il a été battu vais
pas trop ça que pour faire la sieste
après midi que regarder france 2 et qu'à
faire conclure j'adore cet appel il ya
une oeuvre d'art très ancienne qui nous
a rappelé quelqu'un regarde et je viens
membres une belle dame d'autrefois
je pense que ces dix huitième d'une
viennent chaque team bonjour je me suis
tu avais dit à patricia écoutez je vais
je vais dire 150 euros d'accord alors
pourquoi pas plus puisqu'il n'est pas en
très bon état
le sujet comme vous l'avez deviné est
quand même un petit peu difficile impôts
c'était un petit peu difficile
voilà alors elle respire pas la gaieté
novotel elle a été vendu très cher e les
cherry sur w9 qui a les princes et les
princesses de l'amour alors j'ai pas
perdu mon temps puisque il ya le
candidat julien guirado qui m'a appris
une nouvelle insulte alors vous allez
voir l ai pas vu le dire mais elle et
elle est violente et souk où mélanie je
fais demi tour
tu prends la porte au ruban rouge reed
ou nationale
tu fives allez zou par des charentaises
était confiant concert de zazie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel allez vas-y d'avant concert
de zaz connaît quand je me suis réveillé
une masse est tout à l'heure pour
redémarré doucement mais sûrement j'ai
juste regardé la chaîne parlementaire
lcp j'adore et je suis tombé sur une
séquence m'a dégoûté de la politique
regarder mais vous ne répondez pas aux
interrogations de ceux qui n'auront pas
une carrière complète ce qui est la
réalité de nombreux français est encore
plus de maire après votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage bien bon appétit
bien sûr c'est ce qu'on la tayaba vol
c'est le crash n'a pas dans le milieu le
crash net on a une dernière une année un
petit truc pour le plaisir avant de
passer à bien sûr à gogo gossip
on a fait un petit tour sur eder encore
parce qu'on adore avec la question d'une
auditrice à un voyant c'est la question
la plus ripoux du monde
on veut savoir sur un sur sept regardez
juliette quel est votre question par
rapport à l'adresse habituelle que
j'habite un j'ai un gros souci avec le
passé un peu lourd qui vient embrumé mon
présent est ce que vous pensez que j'ai
raison de de contacter la personne
responsable à la mairie parce qu'on
prévient d'un déménagement et ce rien
faire pour le moment
dans un futur proche
j'ai rien compris outre isabelle
[Applaudissements]